uh I've got a lot of gear that I like I
still have shadow price which is my
favorite ear one legendary auto rifle
where am I going to put all this new
stuff uh the vault well here here's the
problem of having so I approach my vault
these are all my favorite year one
legendaries and exotics a tab over this
is all my raid gear this is all the
stuff I want and wait a minute page to
page two of three nice alright so this
is where the fun begins I have a new
vault space tab for weapons armor and
general items let's take a look at what
is in my brand new vault tab ooh there's
a shadow there's my shadow price but it
is level 3 30 attack yes so brought back
some old favorites some old favorites
let's check them out so this will be
this will be mine I mean Mike might
somewhere in a distant vault my sorrows
regime is is turning green with envy
because i love the shadow price and if
it's a level 3 30 gun I'm going into
iron banner with this iron this is gonna
be nice what else we got my favorite
badger CCL is your favorite okay so
that's new and these and these weapons
you know we have them here in the vault
as 330 but if I'm playing the right
activities and I'm getting 330 gear 335
gear using the same infusion system I
can rank these weapons up to 3 35 that's
correct okay so many paths lead to 335
we'll talk about that you know in a few
minutes but for the time being let's
take out let's check out what else we
got Lord High fixer grim citizen three
okay my first legendary yeah I love it
yeah that was that was a nice gun I used
that before I acquired the shadow price
so grim citizen three these I'm not even
going to try to pronounce that one but I
remember using that in the in the dark
below I believe we've got the devil you
know I did have the swarm until I
discovered deviant gravity a courtesy of
dead orbit
I'm still getting killed by a zombie
apocalypse was definitely a popular gun
the ldr 5001 sniper the longbow
synthesis sniper 2 to the morgue shotgun
and the comedian shotgun which I think
probably still has the best piece of
flavor texture of any weapon in the
Destiny arsenal and then we get into
some of the different weapons that the
reef is providing us with actually going
to naturally going to grab this one and
how can we get these these these reef
armaments so these are given when you
turn in your scorecard from the
challenge of elders okay those are the
the high score go awesome okay
you